troy  so now that you've made history you were  talking about what it was like to live  in your car years ago  what would you say to yourself  in those moments when you might have  been feeling like  you're not sure that this is gonna work  out  well my advice for myself back then  really you know i was working on stage  and theater isn't always a great pay and  so sometimes i had to drive really far  out to where the theater was and i  couldn't afford gas to get back home and  so to save money i would sleep in the  dressing room  and sometimes i would sleep in my car  like you mentioned or couch surf and  that was all part of the folks who  supported me back then and so i was a  risk taker and that's what my father  always liked to call me so i'm really  glad that i took those risks even though  i have to admit it was a tough journey  but here's the payoff of all that  struggle so i'm very proud